bonjour m ricky c'est merci d'être
heureux en direct avec nous sur rt
france à l'eure vient de dire la
production de vaccin va commencer sur
l'hexagone alors contre concrètement
qu'est ce que cela veut dire puisqu'on
sait que la france ne produit pas de
vaccin propre à elle-même
et qu'est-ce que cela va changer c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour la souveraineté
sanitaire douloureux depuis le début de
la crise on a payé nos de production
tout soit on teste en masques et même
d'une certaine façon en lits de
réanimation en termes de gestion ou pour
le vaccin c'est une bonne nouvelle que
l'europe et la france se met à produire
des vaccins
ce qui est plutôt encore inquiétant
c'est l'angélisme européens sur cette
question de la vaccination
c'est à dire alors que la france et
l'europe est un peu le les cancres de la
vaccination on va continuer à exploiter
à exporter une quantité assez importante
finalement de deux vaccins alors que
nous sommes à la traîne les etats unis
ont produit sur leur sol des deux ils
ont les ont déployé uniquement pour les
américains le temps d'accéder à l'unité
collective langue dans une situation où
l'europe est plutôt une situation est
difficile des continents les plus
touchés et on va exporter nos deux que
l'on a eu du mal à produire et encore
prendre du retard alors qu'on sait que
c'est finalement inscrit pour atteindre
immunité collective et avoir le plus
rapidement possible une population qui
soit le plus la signer alors c'est quand
même un grand nombre de doses qui va
être produit quatre sites vont être
mobilisés lors quand on parle de pros de
production on parle surtout de
flaconnage n'est ce pas c'est en fait
c'est de gérer tout le processus du
sérum tel qu'il est jusqu'au jour où il
est administré aux malades
exactement pour le cas spécifique de la
france ce sera davantage du flaconnage
de la mise la mise en flacon et après la
dispersion est plutôt un travail de
logistique plutôt que vraiment de
production de principes actifs
c'est très bien il faut les deux
c'est aussi complexes ont lieu sur
démarrage de la vaccination que la
france était plutôt en retard sur ces
questions de logistique par rapport à
des pays comme israël ou les états unis
qui sont très bien débrouillés en terme
de logistique dont nous permis d'aller
très rapidement au plus vite proches des
malades avec les vaccins donc pas faire
trop de hiérarchie entre uniquement la
production de principes actifs et le
conditionnement il faut que les deux
fonctionnent bien parce que si l'un des
deux dysfonctionne c'est tout tout la
vaccination et tout le processus qui est
à l'oeuvre qui sera l'échec est ce que
c'est aujourd'hui une nécessité
également à long terme
voilà de produire sur sur le territoire
français si par exemple on est là on
doit finalement se faire vacciner chaque
année un petit peu comme comme la grippe
est ce que justement des usines
devraient être mises à contribution en
tout cas plus que quatre sites
c'est un bon début mais c'est une
nécessité
ce qu'on a des pulsions qui ne
s'aperçoit reproduiront cette crise
c'est le déclin de l'europe et dans
l'europe des coins de la france à cause
des industries lisation dire depuis de
40 ans on a d industrialiser le pays ont
de moins en moins du sinn et finalement
c'est ce qui nous a manqué pour être
réactif pourquoi reproduire les tests
quantified et elle démasque
quand il nous manquait de masques et là
on a vu des vaccins quand il fallait
avoir des vaccins le plus rapidement
possible donc il ya vraiment un enjeu de
réussir à industrialiser le pays est
aussi un enjeu pour la france et pour
l'europe de garder ses meilleurs
éléments
merci la france elle pas capable de
justement avoir un vaccin france et
alors c'est le seul pays du conseil
sécurité de l'onu à elle pas encore
avoir mis sur le marché un vaccin
c'est pas parce qu'on est une fuite des
cerveaux ce qu'on n'est pas capable de
garder dans intellectuelle de garder nos
savants de garder nos scientifiques
donc on a perdu nos usines et à la fois
perdu les têtes pensantes du pays qu'on
trouve dans une situation où finalement
on est à la traîne la sixième depuis six
ans retrouve la 41e en termes de
vaccination c'est c'est toutes ces
questions là qu'il faudra aussi régler
une fois la crise sanitaire passé se
reconstruire un arsenal indiciels je
pense que ce sera l'une des priorités
alors terrible retour le commissaire
européen en charge de la vaccination
justement avait évoqué l'immunité
collective en europe dès la mi juillet
le 14 juillet une date un petit peu
symbolique c'est un objectif
on va dire crédible tenable alors que
l'on sait qu'il ya énormément de
problèmes justement dans cette
vaccination avec des doses qui
n'arrivent pas à nombreux pas assez
suffisant d'autres vaccins qui sont
encore à risque et qui montre beaucoup
de défiance de la part de la population
il faut faire il faut faire le maximum
sur ses objectifs
la réalisation de cet objectif tiendra
de la capacité de la france et de
l'europe à produire suffisamment vite à
exploiter suffisamment vite les nouveaux
vaccins qui seront mis sur le marché il
n'y a pas payé une forme de bureaucratie
européenne qu'il a fait prendre du
retard sur l'autorisation des différents
bassins sur la répartition des doses il
ya un peu cette méta machine qui a
pénalisé la france à titre individuel au
début la crise et qui est actuellement
en train de pénaliser l'europe
donc ça à peu près les mêmes mots que
nous payons faut là aussi apprendre de
la crise pour être en mesure de
respecter les objectifs et les délais
que nous sommes fixés pas être pris en
étau dans une bureaucratie dans des
décisions de plus en plus à sion merci
beaucoup
aymeric guisset d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général adjoint de think tank
millénaire